meine mutter mich immer nannte eine
gefahr unternehmen ist der neue film von
nicolas winding refn der gerne mal ins
genre nimmt sich da rein frisst und es
dann von innen sprengt wenn er kann das
hat er zum beispiel mit drive gemacht
2011 seine kleinen gosling der ersten
krimi oder ein fehler
und jetzt ist es ein horrorfilm ist es
ein horror film über die junge frau
gespielt von elle fanning wie heißt denn
die kommt in die große stadt und will
model werden wo ist deine karte ich hab
nach jesse ist ganz neu in der stadt
wurde aber gerade von roberta hoffmann
unter vertrag genommen wie alt bist du
schon erfahrungen auf dem laufsteg nicht
so richtig dann zeig uns mal deine nur
krieges also das wichtigste was er mit
dem genre anstellt dass man gruppe
stimmen könnte als eine art
amerikanisierte jalloh also
italienischer schlitz und mord film das
wichtigste was er damit macht ist der
kühl das update auch das sozusagen in
flüssigen stickstoff das heißt er nimmt
jede menge leidenschaften raus die
normalerweise deine rolle spielen zum
beispiel mann/frau geschichten mal das
als eine reine frauengeschichte zwischen
dieser jungen frau die da hin kommt die
noch teenager ist die model werden will
einer anderen frau jena malone die außer
models zu schminken auch leichen
präpariert also ein sehr schöner sehr
grässlicher doppelsinn make up artist
und was dann passiert ist ziemlich
blutig aber eben immer ziemlich kühl
das heißt es ist weniger so ein tumult
und rausch taumel blut wahnsinns h als
vielmehr seien bei lebendigem leib ganz
langsam aufschneiden aus
die absicht ist bei ihm immer den
möglichst definitiven film zu einem
problem das ihn beschäftigt zu machen
und er wollte wahrscheinlich den
schönsten film über hässliches oder den
hässlichsten film über das schöne machen
den es gibt und das ist ganz knapp
schief gegangen weil den besten gibt es
schon nämlich des senders syndrom von
magento von 1996 agentur nämlich ist
deshalb besser weil er die dinge wie weh
tun also die geschlechter dinge die man
frau den die frage wie viel an schönheit
des natur wie viel es kunst und weist
sich das und bekämpft sich dass ein
bekriegt sich das viel stärker in den
fokus und als dieser film der sozusagen
kelter vorgeht aber damit auch ein
abstand schafft der teilweise sogar
unfreiwillig lächerliche sachen
produziert
was allerdings heißt schlechter als
agentur heißt immer noch ziemlich gut
ich höre sind deine eltern tut das muss
echt schwer für dich sein
hast du sonst noch familie niemanden
mehr
aber du hast bestimmten freund man kann
diesen film auf jeden fall empfehlen und
zwar allen leuten die sich über eine
zumutung freuen
sie will ja bloß wissen mit wem du
fühlst